we have four folks in front of us today
we have the honorable Melissa Dalton who
is assistant secretary of defense for
Homeland defense and hemispheric Affairs
we have Jedediah Royal who's a principal
Deputy assistant secretary of defense
for indo-pacific security Affairs we
have Lieutenant General Doug Douglas
Sims II who is director for operations
for joint staff j3
and we have vice admiral Sarah Joyner
who's director of four structure
resources and assessments joint staff j8
opening statements will be made by uh
Melissa Dalton and by General Sims
Melissa Dalton you may start
good morning chairman tester Vice chair
Collins and subcommittee members thank
you for convening this important
Roundtable this morning
I know that the recent events
surrounding the prc's High Altitude
surveillance balloon have directly
affected a number of your States I
wanted to provide you with a brief
overview of events before turning over
to my colleagues and answering any
questions that you have
the balloon entered our U.S air defense
identification Zone and then airspace
over Alaska on Saturday January 28th it
was over Alaska for a short period of
time and then flew over Canada we
continue to track and assess the balloon
learning more about the prc's
capabilities and tradecraft
on Tuesday January 31st the balloon
entered U.S continental airspace we were
able to protect against PRC intelligence
collection which was straightforward
since we knew where the balloon was the
president was briefed that same day and
through National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan directed the U.S military to
refine and present options to shoot the
balloon down
the military recommended taking the
balloon down over water waiting to do so
had three benefits first it gave us
additional time to observe the balloon
again assessing the prc's capabilities
and tradecraft
simultaneously we protected against
intelligence collection which again was
relatively straightforward since we knew
where the balloon was
second this allowed us to refine options
and decrease the risk of debris causing
harm to civilians please bear in mind
the balloon itself was 200 feet tall
with a jetliner size payload we
consulted with NASA who analyzed and
assessed the potential debris field that
the balloon would create based on
trajectory weather and the estimated
payload
and third waiting to shoot the balloon
down over water improved our prospects
at recovery which are ongoing
throughout Wednesday and Thursday we
continue to track the balloon and then
on Friday February 3rd President Biden
was briefed on the execution of a plan
to shoot down the balloon once over
water this plan included the air assets
that we would use to take down the
balloon as well as the Joint Forces we
would use to recover it he approved the
plan and throughout that night national
security staff and the Department of
Defense including joint staff Personnel
worked to ensure this mission was
successfully executed throughout the
night as the president had requested
National Security adviser Sullivan
provided him with regular updates
Saturday morning February 4th President
Biden spoke with secretary Austin
multiple times about the mission and it
was completed as you were aware on
Saturday afternoon when the balloon was
shot down and crashed in the ocean
roughly six miles off the coast of South
Carolina in our territorial Waters
due to rough Seas debris collection
began on February 5th the USS Carter
Hall is collecting debris in and around
where the balloon came down the usns
Pathfinder is using Sonar to map the
ocean floor and search for debris the
Coast Guard is ensuring that the area is
kept safe for both the public and our
military personnel
the PRC is dod's pacing Challenge and
the prc's irresponsible actions were
visible for the American public people
and all of the world to see ultimately
we were able to collect intelligence
from the balloon we are recovering its
contents and we sent a clear message to
the PRC that activities such as this is
unacceptable
is here today to answer any questions
you have about U.S Communications with
the PRC and indo-pacific Affairs we
thank you again for convening this
morning's Roundtable and I look forward
to answering your questions
chairman tester Vice chairman Collins
ladies and gentlemen good morning I
appreciate today's opportunity to update
you on the U.S military efforts related
to the recent high altitude balloon from
the People's Republic of China
as Ms Dalton noted we acquired the
balloon on January 28th
following the radar acquisition of the
balloon as it approached Alaska and
given the determination the balloon was
not a threat to U.S citizens or Aviation
traffic and the lack of a bill of its
ability to conduct significant
intelligence collection at that time the
NORAD northcom Commander assessed and
reported he would continue to observe
and report the balloon's movements he
advised the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
and the Secretary of Defense who ensured
the appropriate senior leaders were
aware of the ongoing situation
as the balloon crossed through Canada
and approached the United States border
the assessment for potential Intel risk
to sensitive critical U.S sites in the
Upper Midwest increased and the
president asked for kinetic courses of
action
in determining potential options the
risk of Chinese intelligence collection
was deemed to be low to moderate while
the risk to U.S Personnel on the ground
was assessed at moderate to significant
given the various debris field models
combined with potential weapon earring
as the assessment for risk to U.S
Personnel outweighed the potential
intelligence loss the recommendation was
made to shoot the balloon down over an
area that minimized the risk to U.S
citizens that location was in the U.S
territorial airspace and Waters off the
South Carolina coast
the recommendation was approved by the
president and executed by the north com
Commander using an F-22 Raptor on
February 4th
the decision to shoot down the balloon
in waters off South Carolina is allowing
for the recovery of the balloon and its
materials and the opportunity to gain
additional intelligence insights on
Chinese balloon and surveillance
activities
it is important to note at any point
along the balloon's path the U.S
military possessed the the authorities
and the ability to shoot down the
balloon in defense of our citizens I
look forward to your questions and
appreciate the chance to be here today
and I should add that vice admiral
Joyner The Joint staff j8 is here to
address any resourcing questions and
I'll do my best to cover operationally
related items thank you I thank you for
Testimony General Sims there will be
questions uh in my particular case you
can direct them anywhere you want to
answer them
um and keep in mind at 11 30 I think we
have a classified briefing in this gift
for all the Senators so we're going to
try to be prompt so the first question I
have is um
when this entered U.S airspace did we
know uh
what they were what the Chinese were
trying to collect did we know
do we know what they were doing do we
know what they were trying to collect
Senator thank you for for the question
um as the NORAD North com Commander has
said
um when the balloon entered North
American airspace Norman had custody of
it and and was tracking it closely as it
transited across Alaska through Canada
which is of course part of NORAD and we
were sharing intelligence of real time
and tracking and assessing with the
Canadians and as it entered the
Continental of the United States we were
able to track and assessment I got the
tracking and I got that I want to know
if we knew what the Chinese were trying
to collect with that balloon with that
reconnaissance balloon
yeah Senator um thanks for the question
um what we can probably get into details
more in the classified settings you can
just say yes or no sir you don't need to
get into specifics just did we know what
they're trying to collect yes or no yes
sir we understand it this is a broader
uh part of a broader Suite of of
operations that China is undertaking so
we we knew what they were looking for
sir we uh I think we should talk about
this more explicitly in the classified
session but yes sir we understand that
this is part of the broader Suite of
operations that China's undertaking to
try and get a better understanding of
U.S I got it I mean there's all sorts of
Suites of operations we have with what's
going on in outer space and everything
but the question is did we know what
that balloon was trying to gather do we
know what information it was trying to
gather from the United States it didn't
fly over by accident
it was intentional do we know what the
Chinese communist government was looking
Senator we have some very good guesses
about that uh and we are learning more
as we exploit the contents of the
balloon and the payload itself okay so
it has been brought to the attention not
in classified session but through the
news that this isn't the first time this
has happened this has happened several
times before
my question is is if we waited to shoot
this one down over water why didn't we
shoot the last ones down over water
Senator I'll take that question
um
we are learning more about the balloon
program we are more aware of this Bloom
program in recent months than we have
been in the past so Senator I think that
our assessments uh are maturing about
the intent behind these balloons and the
operational activity so so let me let me
get this right I I put a lot of faith
into the military uh leadership I've met
with a lot of generals in their Top
Flight folks including the ones here and
admirals
I I put Faith in them because
um I believe they know the issue better
than I do okay
so the real question here is it if we
had an incursion before and we shot this
one down when it hit water why didn't we
shoot the previous ones down and gather
intelligence from those so we knew what
was going to happen and by the way this
is going to happen again
and so
why haven't we
either this is no big deal in the
military's eyes and I don't think you're
going to say that
um or there's not a consistent plan on
how to deal with them
talk to me Senator thank you for the
question if I may just
that Judd was saying um the PRC
government surveillance balloons have
transited the continental United States
briefly
at least three times during the prior
Administration so the question is is why
didn't we why did we why don't we shoot
him down over water then the the
duration of this particular balloon was
was much longer and the information that
we have since gleaned about the balloons
that have transited globally was only
recently discovered
um we can share more in the classified
setting
so
um okay
we're talking about putting a budget
together for the defense department it
was a really robust budget last cycle
um
I don't remember hearing about anything
that dealt with balloons in the budget
um
do we have a plan and how what we're
going to do next time this happens
Senator thank you as you know in the
National defense strategy from 2022 on
the PRC is the pacing challenge I know
but what about the balloons I got I got
all the other stuff and we deal with it
is there is there money in the budget or
if you're not into that if you're not in
that pay grade yep do we have a plan for
when this happens again and what we're
going to do and when we're going to do
it I will tell you this and I appreciate
the but
but the truth is we think we know what
they were going to collect we don't know
that scares the hell out of me
Senator thank you it is incredibly
serious and please know
um as we are recovering the balloon and
learning more about it and also
including that with what we learned last
week we are building our understanding
of what capabilities they have what we
need to do going forward and and what
about and I'm over time and I'm this is
the last thing so you can answer it I
hope do we have a plan for the next
thing that happens and how we're going
to deal with it
um
because quite frankly I'll just tell you
I I don't want a damn balloon going
across the United States
when we potentially could have taken it
down over the Aleutian Islands no
offense to Alaska or Alaska or in some
of the areas in Montana and I understand
Public Health I understand doing damage
I understand that could have been a
nightmare
but the truth is is I got a problem with
with the Chinese balloon flying over my
state
much less the rest of the country
Senator absolutely we sent a very clear
message to the PRC when we shot it down
in our Sovereign airspace in our
Sovereign Waters that has established
that deterrent line Judd if you maybe
turn to you in terms of communications
with the PRC yes thank you ma'am um the
we continue to conduct Outreach to the
PRC we conducted Outreach during the
course of the events last week and have
attempted subsequently part of the plan
is to encourage the Chinese
administration to open their lines of
communication you can tell the folks at
11 30 that in classified session I want
to know what a response is going to be
for the next balloon that comes over
military response sir thank you thank
you
secretary Dalton according to your
testimony January 31st appears to be the
first time that President Biden was
briefed by the Pentagon about the
surveillance balloon which had been
violating U.S and Canadian airspace
since January 28th are you aware of any
existing Department of Defense policy to
treat violations of U.S Sovereign
airspace over Alaska
differently from violations over the
lower 48 states
Senator Collins no I am not aware of
such a policy Alaska is part of the
United States then what explains that
delay
days of delay
Senator
um in on January 28th when the balloon
entered U.S airspace over Alaska
the Pentagon was tracking it very
closely through through NORAD NORAD had
custody of it and there were
Communications with the White House to
apprise them of the balloons was the
president informed I would I would have
to defer to the White House in terms of
internal to the White House Press
Secretary he was nodded according to the
testimony that we heard there were three
to four days before he was informed
Senator I would have to defer to the
White House thank you General Sims
the commander of NORAD and North com
recently said that when NORAD first
detected the balloon as it approached
Alaska he determined that it was in fact
a surveillance balloon but that it did
not present a physical meant military
threat to North America and he explained
that he didn't take immediate action
because it was not demonstrating hostile
attack or hostile intent
why wouldn't a foreign military
surveillance aircraft violating U.S
airspace
inherently be considered to have hostile
intent
ma'am thank you for the question I think
first of all
um just to reiterate the gentleman van
hurk did have all the authorities
necessary should he have determined it
to have been a threat the the key piece
here I think ma'am is there was no
hostile act or hostile intent that would
be the first there was no uh impact to
Aviation routes which would be another
piece of that the other would be there
was no at the time there was no
suspected impact a critical intelligence
gathering ability in terms of
infrastructure that that changed as the
balloon made as its path continued that
changed and that's what prompted a
different decision uh or a different
conversation as it crossed into the
United States
um well Alaska has a lot of and I'm
going to leave this to my colleague but
a lot of sensitive military
installations yes ma'am and the
advantage of a balloon over a satellite
is it can hover over those sensitive
sites yes ma'am and through throughout
the path and as somebody who lived for a
couple of years in Alaska throughout its
path bam they were tracking exactly
where it was in relation to that
sensitive critical infrastructure and
and intelligence gathering capabilities
it was not near those locations and as
we reconstruct the path we are not
concerned with intelligence gathering in
Alaska and based on that the assessment
continued from from NORAD northcom to
continue to observe and report
well it seems to me when you have a crap
that's violating International Air
airspace and you have sensitive military
installations whether they're in Hawaii
or Alaska or the lower 48 we should
treat it the same could you help educate
the committee and the public on why
China is using balloons and what
benefits do they offer over satellites
or other intelligence gathering
platforms
and I don't have a light on here I don't
know
you still have 40 seconds yes ma'am I
thank you
ma'am I I think what we've learned is
that there are there are some advantages
it can loiter but what we think they
gained was really very minor in
comparison to what we think we can gain
with with uh with low earth lower Leo
with low Earth Earth orbiting
um and and that went into the
conversation as as everybody was was
working through the risk and as I
mentioned earlier we deem that risk as
it moved from Alaska towards the lower
48 redeemed that risk to change a little
and we also knew that we had the ability
to mitigate that risk and we'll be able
to talk to that further in the session
following but just to end uh former Air
Force General Charlie Moore who is
Deputy commander of cyber command just
has pointed out that if you have a
balloon that's moving extremely slowly
you have a persistence that you can't
get from a satellite
Senator if I may just to add because we
knew where the balloon was tracking we
took measures to protect those sites per
established protocols that included
sensitive Communications and covering up
certain facilities
thank you
thank you Senator Collins next we have
the chair of the full Appropriations
Committee Senator Murray well thank you
very much Senator tester for holding
this briefing and I just want to say
that the Appropriations Committee is
really lucky to have you at the helm
here on the defense subcommittee and I
look forward to working with you and
Senator Collins in this Congress I want
to start off by echoing what Senator
tester said earlier and I will tell you
as chair of the Appropriations Committee
I appreciate all of you coming before us
today but on issues such as this
especially for senators whose states
were affected I expect this
Administration to be timely and
straightforward with information and
more broadly as chair along with Vice
chair Collins I further expect a very
robust dialogue with the administration
including the Pentagon and The Joint
Chiefs and through that dialogue it is
my priority to have information shared
in a timely fashion to make sure that
all the members of this Appropriations
Committee have a solid handle on matters
impacting this committee and this
country so I want to make sure you all
knew that before we started questioning
let me ask you one of the aspects of
this situation that really concerns me
is when you became aware that the
surveillance balloon had entered our
airspace it seems to me it is critical
we are immediately identifying when
something like this balloon is
approaching or is crossed into the
United States so we can act quickly and
appropriately and that is of course
especially important for states on the
west coast many on this committee who
could be the first impacted by these
threats so I want to know as you tracked
this balloon approaching over Alaska
when did you determine the threat and
did you have constant surveillance for
the entire time it was in the U.S and
Canadian airspace
Senator thank you very much uh for for
your question and it is absolutely our
intent to provide timely information uh
to this subcommittee and to Congress as
a whole
um on Saturday January 28th
um we uh tracked through NORAD that the
balloon was entering U.S air air defense
identification Zone and U.S airspace in
in Alaska and from there NORAD had
custody and and we were tracking it
across the did you have a constant
surveillance that the entire time of the
balloon was yes
um let me ask you do you think there's
any need for additional systems or
Investments to protect against these
high altitude surveillance threats
Senator thank you I'm happy to to start
there and perhaps can turn to vice
admiral Joyner as as well
um as general van hurk um has has
mentioned the department and continues
to be acutely aware of the need to
enhance persistent surveillance of the
Aerospace and Maritime approaches to
North America to that end we are working
closely with our Canadian allies to
modernize nor ad surveillance
capabilities Pace to the current and
future geopolitical environment in the
near term we are taking steps with
Canada to augment the existing North
warning system including development of
a new system of sensors called crossbow
that will enhance norad's ability to
detect approaching Airborne threats
longer-term modernization efforts
include but are not limited to the
construction of the Over the Horizon
Radars in both the United States and
Canada to augment the existing North
warning system and enhance norad's
ability to perform its Aerospace warning
control and Maritime warning missions
vice admiral Joyner
Senator we continue to modernize the
existing systems that we have so that's
been an effort that's been ongoing in
conjunction with this committee and 23
significant investments in both the
space architecture which we think is is
key for future monitoring and
understanding of our environment both
within the United States overseas and
abroad so and then undersea as well
Investments have been made as well to
counter other threats
integrated air and cruise missile
defense the Committees and the Congress
directed us to put forward an
acquisition lead and Air Force is now
the acquisition lead for that effort
they're moving forward out on that
mission Army has the counter uas and
then the overall systems and the
modernization of the Over the Horizon
Radars will enhance our ability to look
long range and give us persistent
forward look in partnership with our
Northern neighbors NORAD northcom so the
modernization is important the existing
systems can meet our needs we continue
to maintain and invest in maintaining
those systems as we modernize
well it is really important that we all
have a real clear handle on incidents
like this in full situational awareness
over west coast states to the Pacific so
I know we're an open session today but I
hope all of you can brief me and my
office separately on the ability and
capability to make sure we can act
adequately identify and determine
threats before they are over the U.S
territory and let me just say this this
incident is greatly concerning to me not
just because of the breach of our
airspace but what it signals about our
relationship with China the strength of
our diplomacy and really the state of
our domestic capabilities this
Appropriations Committee is going to be
taking a very serious look at our
approach to our relationship with China
and I look forward to working with
Senator Collins and with our colleagues
here on this subcommittee and others on
that thank you Mr chairman thank you
Senator Murray uh senator from Alaska
Senator murkowski thank you Mr chairman
and I appreciate that you and the vice
chair have called this meeting so so
timely
um
as an Alaskan
I am so
angry
I want to use other words
but I'm not going to
the fact of the matter is Alaska is the
first line of defense
for America right
if you're gonna have Russia coming at
you if you're going to have China coming
at you we know exactly how they come
they come up
and they go over Alaska
sometimes they go on the top sometimes
they go straight across but Alaska is it
and thank goodness thank goodness the
Pentagon the Department of Defense have
recognized
where we sit
on the globe
to take care of the rest of this country
and thank goodness that we have invested
the resources to make sure that we have
the eyes
on the skies and every place else
more fifth generation Fighters sitting
there in the state of Alaska we know
that we're proud of it
everything that we do to to stay focused
whether it's Cobra daying out in the
aleutians or whether it's clear Air
Force Base that has a long-range
discrimination radar or out in Greeley
where we have
the ground-based missile defense we are
ready
we're ready man
and to the point that Senator Collins
makes it's like it's like this
Administration doesn't think that Alaska
is is any part of of the uh of the rest
of the country here to get to the United
States you've got to come through Alaska
so when we see it first as we did as we
all knew
and as you have suggested Mr Royal I
think you you suggested we knew we knew
when we first got eyes on this
that this balloon was not
a weather station this was not
collecting weather information
we knew that
and so think about it from Alaska's
perspective you said
you said Ms Dalton that the clear
message here we we sent a clear message
to the PRC when we shot this down in our
Sovereign Waters
seems to me the clear message to China
is we got free range in Alaska
because they're not they're going to let
us cruise over that
until it gets to more sensitive areas
tell me tell me where the sensitive
areas are
alaskans have stepped up willingly
and and support our military
but when we're talking about the
Sovereign Waters and The Sovereign
territories of this country
Alaska is part of that
so
I I really I I know we're going to have
an opportunity for more information in
the classified brief I've already
received one
and it was pretty thorough
and I think that the American public
deserve more than they have seen in
terms of transparency
about why why this spy balloon
was allowed to spend two days
over our Waters and over the state of
Alaska
the state that is the guardian for
everybody else
and you're saying
that at that time
at that time there was not a threat to
Alaska citizens or or assets that we
have and that the risk
assessment Rose later as it was coming
into
the rest of the the lower 48 there
you know at at what point at what point
do we say
a surveillance
balloon a spy balloon coming from China
is is a threat to our sovereignty it
should be the minute
the minute
it crosses the line and that line
is Alaska
the question that I have and I
apologize that it's taken me this long
to get to the question but I'm really
concerned about what we have identified
as these data gaps we know that we have
seen balloons previous
that we're also the surveillance
balloons
we didn't realize until later because we
weren't able to do the analysis until
later this committee is the
Appropriations Committee if we need to
spend the money to make sure that we
don't have gaps in our own data that
what we see
is clearly understood we need to know
how to fund that
so Mr chairman I'm over my time
I don't think we'll get the answers that
we need here in this subcommittee
unfortunately we're going to have to get
them in closed hearing but I think
people in this country deserve to know
why the state that is the first line of
defense was not able to keep the rest of
the country from being more vulnerable
when it came to collection of
intelligence as it flew over important
installations
thank you Senator murkowski Senator from
Hawaii Senator Schatz thank you Mr
chairman thank you Vice chair
um
in terms of the sovereignty of our
airspace
is there any distinguish is there any
distinction between
non-contiguous states in the continental
United States
no Senator there's not
in terms of the sovereignty of our
airspace is there any distinction to be
made in terms of international law
between a brief flyover and a lingering
flyover
Senator um the base for us to shoot down
the balloon where we did had a strong
grounding in both domestic and
international law yeah I'm just trying
to figure out whether if they had been
you know let's say they just clipped the
corner of the Florida Peninsula like
let's say they just you know go over
Hawaii for 10 minutes isn't that still a
violation of international law isn't
that still a violation of our airspace
and doesn't it Merit the same kinetic
action that was taken it it is still a
violation of our airspace
is DoD policy changing in this space
Senator what I would say is that as we
learn more about these balloons there
are Global activities
um as we are able to assess the
collection capabilities of this
particular high altitude balloon through
the recovery efforts we are going to be
assessing our overall
um
posture and disposition and strategic
approach and I respect the need to keep
some of this classified but we all
understand that some of the
desire to keep things classified has to
do with not wanting to disclose to the
public things that might be inconvenient
politically for the Department
and so it seems to me that if we now and
look I support the actions that were
taken
but I don't see a downside
to a signaling to any government
that any violation of our airspace that
is not inadvertent and certainly any
violation that is intentional and has a
military component will be met with
immediate kinetic action and it that
just doesn't seem to me to be something
that that there's any benefit to keeping
secret Senator that is not our our
intent and I do believe we have sent
that signal this Hab was different than
the others in terms of the duration of
its flight but that's that's what I'm a
little first of all let's start with
this did we just set a precedent
I believe we established a deterrent
line fine
second of all is that deterrent line
contingent on where they go and how long
they linger or just is it a bright red
line called don't come into our airspace
it it is when there are airspace has
been violated we took action when it was
safe to do so given the risk to
civilians on the ground per the advice
of our military commanders do you expect
the PRC to proliferate these kinds of
programs
Chad you want to take that one Senator
uh we understand this balloon program is
as I said earlier part of a broader
Suite we understand that it is connected
with a broad range of intrusive action
from the PRC with its intent to coerce
uh the United States our allies and
partners so I've heard two different
things in a public setting one is what
the vice chair said which is the
persistence
at lower altitudes gives them better
Fidelity on photos and even you know
other other other information
and the other is look these things are
really deployed because they're cheaper
than satellites so those things seem to
be in conflict with each other
my instinct was always that balloons are
cheaper than satellites and that's
really what this is about but are there
capabilities that balloons have that
satellites don't
Senator thank you for the question we'll
be able to share more in a classified
setting
and when will the damage assessment be
completed
thank you so that's ongoing now we
continue to recover we recover pieces
each day I think we're thinking days to
two weeks in terms of everything but it
does continue in in conjunction with the
FBI so I would like to offer a military
perspective to to your uh comment about
sure you have 22 seconds yes sir
sure I think having been in places where
once you take a shot you can't get it
back I think it's important for us to
remember that if we establish that
precedent that precedent maybe uh met we
may meet the same precedent in which
case as opposed to thinking and looking
and then reacting we may create
something in which we are is to our
detriment
fair enough
senator from North Dakota Senator Hoven
secretary Donald I just uh was listening
to one of your responses and then spoke
with Senator murkowski if you had the
opportunity to shoot the Chinese spy
balloon down either over the remote
mountains of Alaska or over water near
Alaska why didn't you why is it okay to
have the Chinese fly some type of
aircraft over Alaskan airspace sure let
me walk water to land for first the
first would be in in terms of the water
uh General Banner again assessed that it
was not a there was no hostile act
hostile intent or potential impact to
critical intelligence capabilities more
so he was continuing to care to
characterize the system and I it's for
us now looking back there's an assertion
that we were absolutely certain that it
was in fact conducting surveillance or
intended to go in a certain space and
we'll talk more about that in the next
session
um but that was those were thoughtful
actions the the other piece I would add
over the land of Alaska
you know so we spent a lot of time as
you know determining where we will take
a shot in combat when we're fighting
when we're fighting people who are
fighting against us and we work our way
to a near zero probability of collateral
damage when we when we take that shot
although Alaska is in places not as
inhabited as other places it is
inhabited and at that time we didn't
understand through the modeling if we
shot that what it would do on the ground
ultimately it came back to maybe a 20
mile by 20 mile piece of ground and
without being able to clear that it we
we wouldn't do that in combat sure and I
think in this case we certainly didn't
want to take that chance with alaskans
or any other Americans throughout the
flight path so we created a situation
now where our adversaries are going to
kind of try to figure out what they can
and can't fly over our airspace well
maybe a balloon what are they going to
try next UAV a uas or I mean is that
where we're at now they're gonna all try
to figure I mean the Russians test our
airspace all the time and use scramble
fighters to interdict them because
you're saying nothing can fly over our
space that's Sovereign airspace so now
we're in a new day where our adversaries
get to try to figure out what you're
going to let fly over and what you're
not no sure sure I think and and kind of
back to Senator tester's uh earlier
comment I would say first of all we are
certainly grateful for the support from
this committee and for your trust sir
um I would tell you that throughout this
General van irk and the men and women
who were serving under him had American
Safety in mind throughout and at any
moment had it presented some sort of
intent to hurt Americans they would have
taken that balloon out of the sky it
would have happened I would tell you
that is the same should something else
happen General van irk the rest of the
military stands ready whatever threats
come but we do expect that they will
assess and report and in this case her
he assessed and reported based on the
intent and based on where it was at the
time so there's some things they can fly
over or near Hawaii there's some things
they can fly over Alaska but maybe not
over California or possibly over Montana
or North Dakota it's just kind of you
know you decide based on the
circumstance doesn't that create a
situation where our adversaries are
going to test what you think can and
can't fly over different or proximity to
different parts of the country on a
regular basis Senator and is that is
that good how are you going to prevent
that kind of thing from now being tested
you know even more than you already are
and you're going to be in the are you
going to start making subjective
decisions about different types of
aircraft and what proximity and where
they can fly what states they can they
can't fly over or Guam or you you know
pick a spot
this is where it seems to me we're
getting into a dangerous place in terms
of how this was handled Senator if I may
this flight was different than all the
rest and that's why we took the action
that we did
um to the question of building upon
General Sims notes about the why we
didn't take it down over Alaska a key
piece of this is the recovery for us to
be able to exploit and understand this
balloon and its capabilities fully if we
had taken it down over the state of
Alaska which is part of the United
States it would have been a very
different recovery operation as Senator
murkowski knows the water defs offshore
the aleutians at six plus nautical miles
go very quickly from about 150 feet to
over 18 000 feet near the the Bering Sea
the winter water temperatures in the
Bering Sea hover consistently in the low
30s which would make recovery and
Salvage operations very dangerous
additionally the northern portion of the
Bering Sea has ice cover which can be
extremely dangerous which would induce
additional risk so again a key part of
the calculus for this operation was the
ability to salvage understand and
exploit the the capabilities of the High
Altitude balloon and we look forward to
sharing that with you in a classified
session and also openly as we learn more
with the Indulgence of the chairman just
finishing up here um
those are the kind of things I think are
important people want to understand that
people support our men and women in
uniform we appreciate what you do we are
I mean we owe you our lives and we are
deeply thankful for that
but but Americans don't understand this
situation and so they need to understand
why the decisions were made that were
made and you know whether or not that is
what is best for uh National Security
and just the final quick question is
could that balloon not be forced down
some way other than shooting it down
obviously we have aircraft that can
exceed that altitude and so just a final
question could not have been forced down
some way rather than shooting it down
which would have in a lot of ways been
better you avoid the risk to people on
the ground and you get it intact yes sir
sure sir we were
there were and we'll talk in the next
session I believe about some thoughts um
we didn't have the ability to capture
the balloon or bring the balloon down
um with a particular munition that we
thought would would make it uh less
dangerous and quite frankly we we didn't
know where it would go if we were to
somehow impact its flight path at that
point uh in terms of our ability to
control it what it would do if it hit
the ground but that's a great question
sir and we'll I think we'll address that
greater in the next session thank you
yeah so um
secretary blinken canceled a planned
trip to Xing over this incident the
Chinese lost their balloon
that nobody believed was a weather
balloon as a Chinese Republic has stated
do you is in your estimation that this
was an error by the Chinese government
or was this planned
Senator we're continuing to make
assessments on the Chinese intent for
this specific operation and we'll have
further to share in the classified
setting along the specific content I
think it would be false to try to
characterize this operation as purely a
mistake my understanding sir is that
this is consistent with a broader set of
actions China's undertaking to intrude
our Sovereign territory and those of our
allies and partners
so generally speaking as this balloon
won over Alaska Canada in the United
States
who got the most information out of this
the Chinese or us
sir I don't have a judgment or
evaluation to pass along those lines for
you right now I do believe that the
United States collection on this uh this
particular balloon and on the broader
program is ongoing and is significant
Senator Holman said something that is
true not only for the American people is
true for us
we don't understand
we don't understand because quite
frankly we have been briefed in this
committee
over and over and over again
about the risk that China poses
both economically
and militarily
we know for a fact going back to sender
schatz's comments that there have been
brief incursions on our airspace
we didn't do anything about that
we also know that China tends to push
the envelope all the time
until
uh
a line has set down
it should not have been a surprise
that China did this
because nothing happened before at least
to our knowledge nothing's happened
before to them for these over flights
so so the question is and it goes back
to everything that everybody on this
committee has talked about
and that is and I'm not sure you can
answer it in this forum but a violation
of airspace is a violation of airspace
and to know absolutely that this was of
no military threat to us boy I want to
hear more about that in classified
session too because quite frankly
I'm not sure that you can say that
unequivocally
and and to the point that
in Montana for example we have some
pretty
important military assets that we use as
a deterrent
for those folks who apparently
apparently I don't know for sure but
apparently
flyover not accidentally some of those
and the same thing with Assets in Alaska
and the same thing with Assets in the
Midwest
you guys have to help me understand why
this baby wasn't taken out long before
and because I am telling you that
that this ain't the last time we've saw
brief incursions now we've seen a long
incursion what happens next I'm sure you
guys have modeled that out too maybe I
hope if you haven't you should
but in the end
um
in the end
either China's a threat or it isn't
and I think it's a huge threat
when this budget comes forth It's
Senator Collins and I and the rest of
people on this committee and the rest of
people in the Senate and Congress are
going to be working on
I hope this is addressed
in some line item
and not only addressed with dollars but
addressed with actions
on how these monies will be put to work
to make sure that this never happens
again
because quite honestly and I get it you
guys have a tough job by the way and as
I said my opening statement you guys the
folks who are the military whether Rank
and filed or the leadership or the salt
of the earth
but we really do depend upon you to make
the right decision
and I'm not sure I've bought and sold at
the right decision was made but we have
another hearing
that's in classified session
that we'll take that up further Senator
Collins do you have other comments
just a few Mr chairman uh first I would
associate myself with everything that
you just said and the other members of
the committee I think you hear great
frustration and a great deal of concern
about the message that has been sent to
China
a general as I look through publicly
available sources at the at the flight
of this balloon and the bases and
sensitive military sites that have
passed over
its flight pattern clearly is not
accidental would you agree with that
ma'am I I honestly uh I do have some
thoughts on that that will be in the
next session and but but you're right
the the flight path took it over areas
that we would think were concerning and
we are pretty certainly mitigated those
and we'll discuss that in the next
section next session
okay I I look forward to hearing uh the
specifics on that I want to go back to
Senator murkowski's point about Alaska
the U.S airspace over and around Alaska
is known as the Alaska Air Defense
identification Zone it is a huge swath
of their space that includes the
airspace over territorial Waters
military training ranges and very
sparsely populated areas and that is why
it is so hard for us to understand why
the balloon wasn't taken out over Alaska
there's it's sparsely populated there
are territorial Waters it's a huge
defense identification Zone it has bases
it has sensitive aircraft it has
military
equipment that is of great interest to
the Chinese for the exact reasons that
Senator Makowski said and yet the
statement was made that when the balloon
was over Alaska it did not show evidence
of hostile intent how help me understand
that why was it there
ma'am wallet was in Alaska we were
characterizing the balloon
um I would tell you one of the things I
think that's very different from our
country then and you can look at
historical examples is we think before
we shoot and in this case we thought
before we shot and again we'll we'll
talk more about it in other sessions I
think that is something that as someone
who flies around and Admiral joint or
certainly more than I that we would
appreciate of our of our uh of the rest
of the world that they would think
before they shoot once you shoot you
can't take it back it ma'am I'll be
quite honest as an American I understand
the the impact and the unsettling
feeling that's here as as someone in the
military who sees that the other side of
that I am very confident in the
authorities that were granted to the
NORAD North com Commander to make
decisions here that the decisions he
made were in the best interests of the
United States and our citizens as were
the decisions of our senior leadership
and and we'll present more of that
conversation in the next session
I'm not implying that we want to be
anything like the Chinese government in
asking this question but do you think if
we had an American
surveillance balloon going over
sensitive Chinese military sites that
the Chinese government would have for a
minute hesitated before taking it down
I'll
not answer on behalf of the Chinese but
I think as an American if I was if I was
flying in that direction I would hope
that they would think before they made a
decision
well I got to tell you I would think
they would not hesitate if we violated
their
territorial airspace to disable and take
down our surveillance platform
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you uh
Senator Collins
um one of the things that was brought up
and then I'm probably going to wrap it
up unless you have more Susan Collins is
that um
uh you spoke about Communications Mr
Royal uh with China could you give me a
brief update on where we're at from a
communication standpoint with China is
it is it totally cut off or are people
still communicating and talking
uh Sir with respect to this particular
operation we engage China on an urgent
matter uh during the course of our
observations of this particular
operation a subsequent to that our
diplomats engaged to make sure that the
Chinese knew that the secretary
blanken's trip would no longer be
possible under the current circumstances
and then further engage the Chinese
subsequent to the successful Downing of
the balloon to make sure they understood
what activity we were undertaking and
why we did that I will say more broadly
sir that it's really important during
moments like this that we maintain open
lines of application and unfortunately
the the Chinese administration has
declined the request from secretary
Austin to communicate directly with his
counterpart in China we believe that
China needs to be more responsive to the
United States when it comes to requests
for further communication I I couldn't
agree with you a hundred percent and the
fact is they're the ones that violated
our airspace and they should be open to
Communications because it was a serious
violation and thinking everybody's
opinion we appreciate you all being here
today we appreciate your answering the
questions and your testimony I think
this was helpful as an initial
conversation but I will tell you that
knowing Susan Collins very well uh
oversight isn't going to stop here we've
got important responsibilities in that
vein and we will continue to do that
whether it's on Chinese threats to our
airspace or any other thing that deals
with the Department of Defense
um and so with that thank you for the
work you guys do every day this defense
subcommittee will re will reconvene on
Tuesday February 14th at 10 A.M
for a classified briefing to discuss
other Chinese threats to the U.S
Homeland thank you all and we stand in
recess